- We're in Mexico and we
had to stop by Starbucks
because there are three
cool drinks that we found.
And we're gonna try it.
(wind whipping)
(hinge squeaks)
(techno music)
- My go to drink for Starbucks
is usually an iced chai.
- Iced vanilla latte.
- Just a regular latte.
- I like espresso Frappuccino.
- Recently I've just been
having a lot of cold brew.
So this is going to be interesting
how different.
- Yeah.
- And sugary (laughs) it is.
- Oh yeah.
(upbeat music)
- So this is Cajeta Frappuccino.
- Excellent.
- I never get the super sugary drinks.
Just looking at this is a little bit
like wow.
- Yeah.
- That's a lot.
- It has some chocolaty chunks?
- Yeah chocolaty chunks
and chocolate dust.
Oh.
- Wow.
- It's intense.
- It's really good.
- It's definitely not something
I would order on my own.
More than a couple sips
of that is just too much.
- Definitely a bigger punch
then just like a caramel frap.
- I like it, wow.
- I would get a sugar high from this.
- The coffee was stronger than I expected.
- I would get this.
(wind whips)
- I've never had Mexican
hot chocolate before.
- [Juan] Oh, you're in for a treat.
- I always order hot
chocolates from Starbucks
so I'm pretty excited for this one.
- So what's the difference
between hot chocolate
in the US and Mexican hot chocolate?
- There's a very specific
brand called Chocolate Abuelita
and it's just a little bar of chocolate
that you put in a pot and
then there's a little tool
that you use.
It makes it nice and frothy.
- Whoa.
Oh this is great.
- Are you into it?
- I feel like I should
be wrapped in a blanket
in front of a fire.
(laughs)
- It smells very heartwarming.
- It is like Christmas day.
- There's something besides the cinnamon.
- Nutmeg kind of like feel.
- I would always have
this during Christmas.
- Yeah I can see it as a
Christmas drink, totally.
(wind whips)
- This is a Mango Frap.
It doesn't smell like mango.
- I'm nervous about this one.
- It looks like pumpkin.
- This will be interesting.
- That's refreshing.
- That's actually really good.
- That's sweet.
- Not really a fan of
sour mangoes in general.
- I love sour stuff so that's
probably why I like it.
- I think this is the
equivalent of a berry refresher
at Starbucks.
Definitely towards the Mexican flavor.
- Mexican Starbucks.
(bell rings)
This was by far my favorite.
(wind whips)
- I would have to say the
(bell rings)
hot chocolate was my favorite.
(wind whips)
- So nostalgic
(bell rings)
to holiday cheer.
(wind whips)
- This impressed me
(bell rings)
because it was fresher,
a bit more sour.
(wind whips)
- I love
(bell rings)
the Cajeta Frappuccino
it is very intense.
- Summer, Fall and Winter.
This covers your whole year.
- It does.
- Which I love.
(wind whipping)
(hinge squeaking)